we were actually talking about LS house
are you familiar with Lou house school
of greatness like his YouTube channel is
blowing up what does he do different
between his YouTube channel and his
audio Channel there's big
differences his audio Channel you kind
of have the opportunity to maybe have
the hook at the beginning you maybe have
a couple ad spots you know you have that
conversation it's unpacking um you maybe
Define who the guest is you go through
all that kind of stuff so we watched one
of his videos with Alex fosi right and
and the beginning of the video is just
into it it's a really broad appeal
question he had you know Grant Cardon
now on him he's like he's like so how do
people you know protect their wealth in
recession boom right into no intro of
Grant no no sponsor spots no anything
else and it just gets straight into the
content so I think this I know this can
be overwhelming for someone who's like
just starting or thinking about man it's
hard enough to just sit down and record
a podcast now I'm recording different
audio different video but I think you
really want to contextualize it for the
platform I think that we you got to
think a little bit different about
YouTube at least a little bit different
if not kind of have a different approach
um in terms so we're already thinking
about like trimming a lot of the fluff
out of our video podcast same episodes
and we're already desynced in terms of
the numbers you know meaning we're on
like episode 155 of our audio podcast
and we're on 300 of our YouTube channel
because there's clips and there's other
things happening and are you trying to
so if you're kind of having the core
content the same I think the nuance
people who are really going to win are
going to apply the different nuances to
YouTube is maybe trimmed down maybe the
brand spot isn't there it gets right
into it um you know the even the title
might be a little bit different because
you are still trying to get that
click-through rate versus on the audio
podcast people are just bought in like
you said they're just like they're
subscribed that's part of their RSS feed
they love there's some trust there the
the audience retention a lot of people
make it 80% 90% into it because they're
working now they're you know they're
doing chores like they're just kind of
listening YouTube's sort of a different
game and I think you don't have to go as
Extreme as I just said but I think even
just a small attention to detail and the
nuances of the platform could be the
difference to making YouTube really work
for you give me the psychology behind
having multiple channels yeah so at this
point again a lot of those other
channels were projects lessons uh right
now it's think media and our think media
podcast Channel I do think if you have
the resources there may is something
about having um a separate channel for
your video podcast and that was what we
originally kind of started it for was it
was our podcast Channel it also was
because the other channel already had a
promise to it and this is the way you
should be thinking so think media mainly
teaches what camera should I buy for
YouTube what's the best camera for
YouTube how do I set up my lighting how
do I set up my audio and lots of nuances
video editing software a little bit of
YouTube tips and strategy so the
expectation there heavy Tech you know
heavy tech reviews Tech tutorials so we
figured if we're launching a video
podcast that's about kind of YouTube
marketing and business strategy even
more when it comes to YouTube does that
really fit the tone of the room you know
does that meet the dress code of of
think media and that was that's the
original way we thought no it doesn't
plus we want to start fresh and we want
to also build up diversifi our audience
and get people who are truly passionate
um you know one of the experts on our
team Omar alori he's like the top
ranking guy for video podcast he has
like 20 video podcast videos on YouTube
and he talks about it also is audience
expectation think media had been
expecting camera videos camera tutorials
and if all of a sudden we start hinting
with 30 45 minute episodes about not
exactly what they want again we sort of
violated the trust for which they
subscribed for force it and they could
choose not to watch it but we didn't
want to MK up the channel in that regard
so once we start the vid we literally
also have podcasts in the title so the
second channel is called think media
podcast not everyone is going to make an
association of what that means but many
will they'll go okay so this isn't
trying to just be right to it
hyperedited entertaining this is longer
form
conversations and so that was the
original reasoning for starting it and
then it also gave us a place for where
our show shows would live we don't
really have shows on think media it's
answering specific questions reviewing
specific products teaching specific
skills whereas what what evolved on our
podcast channel was not just our weekly
podcast but Heather tus on the team
started the YouTube Made Simple show and
I started the coffee with canel show
which don't go on podcast they're just
live stream shows um and then what
really gets interesting is how we slice
and dice all this stuff and just post it
wherever so well we might do a great uh
I I did a recent episode on like courage
on YouTube Secrets it's the first SE and
and the podcast version is like 18
minutes well if you really want to make
a great YouTube video out of that you
could probably get it down to 11 maybe
nine with a good editor and because I'm
not greeting the podcast I'm not saying
welcome back I'm not saying leave a
review of the book trim all that out so
what's interesting is there's like the
podcast episode recorded but we almost
can use that same asset now turn it into
think media version strip all call to
actions out get straight to the point
and we'll get you know 11,000 10,000
views on the podcast we get 55,000 on
think media and that's where we're at
because that momentum it's a bigger
Channel but like the level this holiday
we're gonna uh upload like our best of
we'll upload like five we'll upload you
know Lewis how and Evan carmichel their
best performing videos are two to three
hours
long and so I'm excited because in going
into Christmas week which Christmas hits
on a weekend this year but going into
like the holidays everyone shut down
we'll have five scheduled uploads all
repurposed content and one of the videos
we'll upload on think media since that's
technically five over the weekend total
we actually we'll go Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday Christmas I
think is Saturday and uh uh or Christmas
Eve is Saturday Christmas is Sunday but
like call it that week everyone's shut
down that week no one's uploading that
week we'll upload five videos but
they'll all have been edited probably
like weeks earlier and they will be what
we call content marathons and one of
those we'll just take like our five best
video podcast episodes stitch them all
together throw some what what a lot of
times Omar and Heather will put on like
Christmas swe sweaters and like host a
ton You' think like would anyone want to
watch this like people they're at home
they don't want to hang out with their
family like Uncle Larry's weird dude you
know what I mean and so they go in the
room they're like no one's uploading
like everyone's on Christmas break and
like oh cool than media like I'm going
to turn this on and and so what's Wild
is actually those typically perform
really well but I'm sorry when you say
five videos are you saying like super
long videos long the podcast is 25
minutes long times five it'll be a two
hour content Marathon oh so you're
saying goodness C so you're saying five
two hour videos every day I mean yeah
well yeah there'll be one two hour video
every day for like five days yeah so so
what we did a couple years ago and it
crushed we did did we do office tours so
because we all work from home so it's
like Omar's office tour Heather's office
tour Sean's office tour three separate
videos during the holidays we stitch
them all together same uploads on
YouTube all stitched together that did
better than they did
individually and and we host them so
there's like some strategy to it there's
like a hook like hey are you looking for
some inspiration for your office you're
going to see different styles and you
have you know you got literally
different styles you have you know kind
of a it's not really like shabby chic
but that's just the word that comes to
mind for like Heather you kind of have
that female whatever so and then we time
code it out people can skip around and
you know the average view duration of
this is only like 12 minutes of the hour
and 10 minutes that the video is but 12
minutes is like triple the average on
YouTube like the average view duration
of a video on YouTube is around four to
five minutes so if you're holding
people's attention as they skip through
this video for 12 YouTube rewards that
video like crazy a lot of times we'll
get 20 to 30 to 40,000 views on a video
I think that video got1 5,000 views and
we really just we done all this work
during the year we just put them into
buckets basically so we combined um
office tour videos you could combine
interviews you could and we also think
about like and our we just group things
like microphones like the ultimate
microphone video and and the fact is
there's shotgun microphones there's USB
microphones podcast microphones so
taking all the ones you already did and
just putting them together right there
man was worth people showing up for the
podcast today I mean that's yo yo
somebody take all of like the women and
like let's put something together like
all of the women and then like all of
the financial experts just remind me
that we're gonna do that okay seriously
send me a text to that actually and
that's what that's what Lewis will do is
he'll group because he has such a
backlog of interviews he'll group his
interviews into topics it's up so he'll
go like you know seven wealth building
tips you know for getting rich or
something like that and he'll put he's
had Robert kosaki on and like you know
someone else about money mindset and so
he'll he'll cluster those things
together so of course the strategy
working is happens on the other side of
P publishing a lot of great content but
I would Advocate heavily that people are
not repurposing and reusing anywhere
near enough and not very intelligently
because these this content is assets and
and the myth is is people go yeah well
what if someone's like in the comments
and they go you already uploaded this
you know or someone complains and says
you know man you're just getting
repetitive on the channel and it's like
one I have seen that comment twice two
it was two comments on a 22,000 viewed
video with 2,000 likes three Ricky is
living in his mom's dude don't watch the
video bro if you already saw it like
it's G to be okay like this is think
about and where we got ter unbelievable
content Marathon was you know once you
take that show like The Walking Dead or
something like any show Simpsons like
they do marathons so the shows have
already come out but you can watch them
all in one you know sequence uh Al
together and guess what your option is
oh I already watched them I don't want
to watch the marathon like it's going to
be all right bro but the other fact is
people are also just discovering it or
they or repetition is the father of
learning and the mother of Mastery it's
like I want to watch it again and
there's so much noise in the world um
and online and there's so much
competition people also forget so they
don't even know they've watched it
before that's a fact and so yeah this is
a really slept on strategy um because I
think you can get a lot more longevity
out of your content and with all the new
subscribers you're getting if you
combine you know some of your best stuff
then the new upload do better than it
previously did question for you are you
finally ready to commit to starting and
growing your YouTube channel in 2024 if
the answer is yes you're not going to
want to miss our epic holiday sale going
on right now where you can get over 98%
off of a bundle of our online courses
and downloadable action guides that will
help you crush it on YouTube just click
the link around this video to get access